and especially like you know I you've
got a aux cord yeah right what would be
the biggest pet peeve bigges happy I
mean you're getting into my car yes my
home my sanctuary the last thing I want
you to do is leave trash in my car oh I
don't like when they think I don't know
they spilled their drink in the back
clean it up if there's a ride six to ten
minutes and you are adamant about the
right way to go I'm like I'm pretty sure
that you're gonna still get there and
sensitive minute yeah yeah this is
pretty good my pet peeve is someone that
eats at least without asking if you go
to someone's house that you've met for
the first time do you just open up a bag
of chips and eat over there rug I had a
passenger come in to the passenger side
with a plate of cake as we were driving
just eating it with their hands yeah
when you pick up a bunch of drunk people
and they want you to stop at a bar yeah
jack-in-the-box yeah and you and it's
like 2:00 in the morning pick up a bunch
of drunk people and then they're like
and also just some of the sound effects
stiff someone just came in it wasn't
very late at night and they had an apple
and I knew they had an apple did you
ever get hit on the words most women I
would say don't hit on them at the
workplace I don't like that I would pass
injure snoo I don't like when you ask me
for my phone the strangest thing for me
is getting hit on in a pool if you're
gonna hit on me get your own ride okay
get your own ride to hit on me I had one
uber passenger that said he liked female
drivers because he would like to look at
their legs
my god yeah that sounds right if there's
no one else in my car and then they
automatically sit in the passenger seat
alright come on now
I Drive a Yaris if still gets in my car
and gets up front I only have a problem
with it if you don't speak the whole
ride Oh like like imagine messenger of
it I got in I said how are you yes
exactly
I think the best part about it is when I
ask them so you know why do you sit
front occasionally I will ask them why
people sit upright they'll be like well
I feel weird sit in the back and I go
well why the D emotion sadness no I just
feel like you're driving me somewhere I
have that plenty of Arc pass meters
farting in my book they fart when the
windows are up - I'm like roll the
window down
then pass the gas this is one if someone
is playing music they will reach out and
they will twist out and they will turn
they will fiddle with the stereo like
this one really drunk guy he was I
believe in the bar and he was like
turning it up like the bass speakers are
like I'm turning it down no man for sure
for sure for sure no no it doesn't mic
for sure not for surely not it's not for
show if the speaker's blow out four
stars does not mean good it actually
means fail when you put five that means
thank you for the ride I appreciated it
when you put four it means I want you to
get fired so be respectful that's a big
one I can't say my own says thank you to
me I'm like you're welcome alright a lot
of the times let's say a passenger is
right off the bat like pissed or
something like that I'll pick them up
and I'm like I don't know what happened
I had another driver on its way and then
that driver cancelled so then I had to
wait five minutes for you
and I'm like I have no idea what
happened before your name popped up on
that phone so to summarize I would say
just be aware that we are driving you
but we are also driving other people and
just be courteous of other people that
are going to be in this ride that are
going to be sharing in this car
no one's having the same day as you like
I have to be on top of the world you
know as I pick you up just like man
picking up Shelby like let's see where
Shelby's going you get into the car and
right off the bat you have a problem
with me I'm like well jeez like now the
relationship we could have formed this
has been tainted so it's like always
remember that a driver is also a human
we have feelings
[Music]